hello everyone dave and karen of film
courage here on the line with blogger
and author rihanna carp Rihanna's book
the girls guide to homelessness God is
there yeah we have it it was said that I
was released in april of this year and
her website girls guide to homelessness
dot-com accompanies the book welcome
Brianna thank you for being here thank
you so much for having me yeah I also
want to thank you for joining us Brianna
you know we discovered your story I
think it was just last week on the front
page of yahoo yeah yeah it really caught
Karen's attention and there was a sort
of some connection there and she really
wanted the opportunity to speak with you
so we're just thrilled that you'd better
join us here today yeah thank you so
much really and we want to inform our
listeners of the story leading up to the
book so that they have an idea of you
know what you've been through and what
you've accomplished um so please stop me
if I if I'm incorrect here but I believe
in 2008 you were 23 and you had this
great job as an executive assistant a
job that you absolutely loved and took
pride in um you're making a great salary
50,000 a year you had this cute place in
Orange County a great dog and things are
going well and then the great recession
hits you're laid off and you're given a
severance package and you're eligible
for unemployment benefits but things
just weren't continuing well you picked
up some temp work and he unfortunately
had to give up your place and move in
with your family all right that
situation unfortunately wasn't the best
it was an abusive home situation and you
eventually moved at the same time I
believe you inherited your deceased
father's trailer 34 travel trailer and
you were forced to move into it and live
in a Walmart parking lot walmart at the
time was willing to let certain trailers
be there I understand and yes I what a
policy of that for quite a while Vegas
sam walton on walmart you know was the
big camper so they had a policy of
letting people who you know where
I went through you know in n vacationing
let's stay in there in their parking lot
and I spoke to the general manager asked
if there was kind of a time limit on
that policy um and I was like what is
what if I don't know quite how long I'm
going to be sing and she was like you
know what we're seeing a lot more people
with the recession you know we've been
here for a long period kinda for several
months Owen kind of just look the other
way so she's like just kind of lay low
stay in the corner with the other
campers and then help you say fine right
okay so you're there you still have your
dog you're using your laptop and your
phone and you're able to use the Wi-Fi
at starbucks and you're very resourceful
you you're able to use I believe a gas
station bathroom and you keep yourself
going despite an extremely painful
situation that would really crush most
people and in doing so you turn this
experience into the book the girls guide
to homelessness right and you know I met
a lot of other people living the way i
was making toast probably the scariest
thing about it was that my story wasn't
you know i was finding my story wasn't
really exceptional you know it's you
know fast becoming very very common and
you know the mobile who was living out
of campers and vehicles there's a large
scrying subset of the homeless
population and so I agree have been
raised to think of all those people i
think is most people even do them need
your stereotypes and you know to think
they were all dirty or lazy or that way
because they deserve to be more people
say you know were all simply yell at
drug addicted i just found some really
nice people you know that was most of
the people that i found they were just
great people how to run a hard look and
we're trying to get back on their feet
and blend in and just you know get life
back on track no Briana that I mean
there's a lot of truth a lot of honesty
you know and a good amount of pain in
this book I can all imagine you know
what it's like for you to put this story
you know your story into words I mean
can you talk a little bit about you know
going to where you had to go to to put
put put your surround paper oh sure um
you know it was really scary for me I
didn't think of myself as an author
I had been anonymous and I was plugging
anonymously you know I had the growth
kind of homelessness from the website
which is kind of how this all came about
but it was important to stay anonymous
because you know there was a shame
factor of obvious with the stigma to it
um I didn't want my family to know you
know I was kind of hoping not to have
fun you know all bridges as possible and
I you know I didn't think of myself as a
real writer and I didn't think I have
very kind of talk to go there and you
know as I said there are some really
keen enough doses let's go and there's
some great stuff in there so that took a
lot of coaxing and kind of a lot of
mental mental mental gearing up and but
I am glad identified a lot of people
write me and say that they've been
touched by and not just you know people
who are homeless before my homeless but
you know people who grow up in abusive
household more than you know victimized
by domestic violence isn't connected but
virtually cooling me to know that you
know I may be effective even a handful
people larger just giving them something
to connect to which is really cool but
yeah the book itself was you know it was
a definitely a no the labor of love in
the room you know there's a lot of
exercise and even d'Oleron stuff you
know and personal you came but it was
cathartic and I'm I'm you know I ended
up being real glad that I did was he can
in the initial stages of your moving
into the camper was it your friend
Brandon that suggested that you start
writing about it and I he did he yeah we
were talking about it and he I think
like me was was thinking that it would
be a pretty temporary situation and then
I get myself out of it free quick you
know I don't think they predicted by how
long the recession was dragged on but he
was like oh you should blog about being
homeless you know that's what all the
kids are doing these days right is
blogging and I was like oh that's
beautiful hover something oh so you know
I did it like I did one love those kind
of as a joke and then it felt really
good that felt really Sephardic so I
kept doing it and it was more for me
than for anything else they didn't
expect people to keep breathing but you
know kind of slowly and then you know
more snowballing you know had you know
burner to following I guess and it was
interesting to me to think that any way
would care what i wanted to say or read
it much less come back to be carrying a
surrogate it was kind of exciting time I
open so main just how many people could
connect with with you know my personal
story so how many people are going
through similar stuff right now yeah
what I think is so amazing is you know
you're in your early 20s and you're able
to write about this so beautifully you
know so many people who come from
dysfunctional environments they don't
realize that this is not the norm and I
just think that's amazing that you were
able to just articulate all that was
happening to you and and show people and
help them because like I said so many
people there they're kind of sworn to
secrecy with so much that goes on in
abusive households and that you were
able to be so free and honest with it
that's really commendable yeah the
really difficult in kind of been a
learning experience for me in that you
know I I love to be successful than you
I was raised in a very insular kind of
high control you know use a typed poke
through so you know I like to said you
don't know what was normal and not I
didn't have I mean in in some ways it is
help you know was a swift sword like you
know growing up that way it you know a
dim view was a lot of determination and
the high work ethic i think if i started
working so early to support my family
i'm done the other hand you know i went
out you know moved out at 18 and I had
to kind of learn normal human
interactions operational scratch so I
think a lot of the book is like a coming
of age story because most people have
learned this stuff when when they're
young and I didn't really have any event
that childhood you know normal childhood
teen experiences so I had to do it later
and so you know it i think that a lot of
compelling rage part of it wow you know
i don't know why i'm gonna bring this up
Brianna but when I was 14 I was
skateboarding and I and I and I went up
this ramp and I kind of when I was
skidding across the top of the ramp I
kind of lost my balance and I fell down
and I busted up my arm pretty bad i
broke
it I broke it in two places here and
here and my wrist popped out and I
remember sort of grabbing my wrist and
and and I couldn't understand like why
would this happen to me you know and I
asked myself like why what why you know
I just I was like a two weeks away from
starting high school and in here I am
just completely doing this to myself and
it was just that that travesty and and
some of the things that you've gone
through and you've experienced I mean
have you looked at yourself and say you
know what why me why have I gone through
this definitely and I think that's
everybody you know obviously you know
there are people who have had it much
worse off than me we didn't have you
know a you know a trailer to live in you
know or they're somatic park bench so
you know you try to keep everything in
perspective but yeah there's definitely
moments fearless what else could
possibly go wrong something else does
you're like why why me and I think it's
times like those like where I'd really
like to believe in a concept like karma
or something that seems like you know
that she's like positive it stings come
back to good people of bad things come
back to that people that you know you
see really simplify things happen for no
reason to people who are essentially
very good people and you know you start
to wonder you know about that like how
sure could it really be so you know as
much as I want to believe I concept like
that yeah you would rather just say why
when there's just no sense to it you
know on the other hand like some really
good things have come out of a really
common situation you know for for me and
I you know made met some amazing friends
you know on the journey incredible
family choose things so you know you
look back later and go okay maybe
something positive out of it and you
know I just find a passion in helping
people you know a co-founded world
homeless a lunch last year and had
participation in over 100 countries so I
look back and go you know okay maybe it
is that something like that was you know
that that's the positives I can take out
of it you know something bad happened
with me that I try to turn it to is in
use as possible and I kind of found a
passion helping people which I don't
think I would ever found if you know I
just kind of seemed to be done normal
middle-class you know suburbia life
and where do you think that inner
strength comes from to be able to take
you know all the bad you've had to face
it and then somehow spin that around and
not a lot of people have that ability
where does that come from I think you
know I think most people do have that
ability innately I think you just don't
know how strong you are until you get
put in the situation like that am I
definitely gonna think you know if you
asked me you know if I have been able so
you know being home listens like turn in
a new book so I would have been like no
you're crazy like I saw none of this
coming you know and so I think that it
you know awesome are you okay with the
video i think what is on but I you know
I just you know obviously I was lucky in
some ways you know more than most and so
I try to turn that to good use what I
think most people have that that in a
way that I know strength and I think
some of it also comes from you know
growing up in an abusive childhood and
you know you're kind of you start with
the odds stacked against you in a lot of
ways and that you know he in advertently
you know easy with some determination
and then drive like I was very
differences to get out there and kind of
go on and make my own life and yeah
maybe that quality came in handy when I
take 101 well you wrote about you know
you're still in the trailer and you said
you know I if I can keep my mind and my
body intact I can make it out of this
and that's your book important resource
I mean you can live everything in the
world that you need still got yourself
and so you can try to use whatever you
have a full macula bag so was that
determination that you spoke of you know
having grown up where the odds were
stacked against you and you sort of had
that built-in determination sort of the
you know pushing the elephant up the
hill so to speak is that what kept you
from just spiraling into a total
depression okay I mean a lower yeah I'm
not gonna lie there were definitely very
depressing moments like there were times
where you know you just want to curl the
cry or display
you know um and you you you have to kind
of take that on the chin and you know
they would come in waves and you let it
pass and then I mean what's your other
option you can't sit there feeling sorry
for yourself forever often so you gotta
just keep moving so but now you need he
doesn't link those are depressed fulness
I mean that's part of people of
homelessness yeah you've lost all it out
of me and you're you know you can feel
invisible of times and like you need is
there's a lot of meddling you know
really furiously just to stay in place
but um yeah it's kind of thing where you
don't stop moving you guys definitely
wear like a shark or something dude so
um yeah yeah you get the crisp or any
kind of picked up and say okay what do I
do next and don't wala letter Breanna
just just to maybe give though anyone
who might come across this video just to
give them some further perspective it
would you mind sharing you know a little
bit of the darkest day or you know one
of your darker days kind of kind of what
you were dealing with you know more
specifically I me know probably the
scariest part for me was the first night
because you know is that like I've ever
been home was born in fat accepting and
you know the label of the stigma and
then you know another you probably my
lowest point was i meant another
homeless activists and we cooperated and
we fell in love and um you know that
ended up taking rather badly we were
together for for nearly a year were
supposed to get married in three months
and um it ended up you know of kind of
with he ran off with another woman I you
know in a number that senses like you
know from sleeping in the snow for a
couple nights so that was you know
probably my lowest moment and it was
sort of the give someone that I grown to
really love and then trust you know
Victoria wrote badly and so that was
kind of on top of the list of things
that was probably the hottest yeah I had
to go now I just want to switch gears
just a little bit to a happier point in
that your writing is absolutely poetic
it's you
and yeah I mean you take these memories
that some of them are just horrific and
no one should have to experience them
but you take the reader right there and
you paint these very vivid pictures were
you trained to write how did you develop
this ability no i mean like i like to
write when I was a little kid I like to
write poetry and I was like I'm gonna
write a book one day but like I said I
was raised to kind of a doomsday cult in
anything you know artistic is just
looked on in like in vain and so my you
know my family was like on a very cute
but years not going to write about flips
often like that so you know I kind of
had that you know stripped of me in an
early age and so you know I was alerted
in high school who walk around and they
look a lot you know Rose like journal
entries but um I given up on any dream
of running a book and you know I've
never you know been trained or anything
so um it's really weird to hear people
say that they connected with us they
thought it was poetic because I you know
like I personally read my writing and
I'm like oh god I think that's terrible
and I think I'm a terrible writer so you
know I'm probably like the harshest on
myself but thank you very much that you
love me absolutely and now things are
totally different do you ever get
flooded with memories that are painful
and if so how do you deal with them and
how do you pick yourself up oh yeah I
mean you know I'm not still dealing with
some of it I'm not other with you and I
hear you know every every day from
people who are you don't home lesson
filin's so if you know that can you know
that that's difficult we want to help
people and so um its importance you
needed to keep on doing that obviously
no I have a nine-to-five job which is
really cool and you know by the founder
master artist almost two years of living
so I do that you know that pays the
bills and then you know every over the
rest of time i have is promoting the
book and getting the word out on
homelessness and you know running
uniworld homeless day which is you know
full-time job in it of itself and you
know so if it keeps you on your toes you
don't have a lot of time to get the rest
of the guys you have that moment when I
others there sounds I mean you know and
remembering what you went through but
like look
with gained out of relativity people
that I've met and you know the
connections that that I've met but you
know I found my family and my passion
for this so you know it's hard to her
friend units fight that the bush you
know the hardest things that happen just
because you know so much good has come
out of it and I'm you know that's like
you really cold heat transfer and
women's under my name you know Briana
you know speaking of the brighter side I
mean can can you can you you know what
has been the most you know moving part
of this experience you know is there a
specific moment with someone a stranger
or fan you know just this the moment
where you could really see sort of the
spiritual side of why this has all
happened to you oh you know I like the
best moments for me or um when someone
who write in and say you know I thought
the same way you know about how existing
you changed the way I thought about it
like so once the ones that I know how
hard it is to change so much you know
perceptions I mean stereotypes people
you know it's hard for me to change my
own so if you know something like that
really moved me or when you know I've
gotten letters from someone who's like
I'm firm with you people were like I'm
16 years old and I was raising abusive
family or I have a bipolar mother or I
was sexually abused as a child and like
thank you giving something back to and
that to me is you know like that makes
my day that's what it's all about
everything else is just great baby cuz
you I feel like you know I touched one
person like personally I mean that you
know you can't put a value on that and
that's probably that the most living
things like that threat to install any
other so this is also funny i'm getting
the like okay i'm in san francisco time
you know getting to you know talk about
it and stuff but like yet for the
personal connections you know with Luke
readers well as we mentioned earlier
your story was on the cover on the front
page of yahoo just recently you've also
been interviewed on the Today Show CNN
and numerous radio
and online publications how was that
sort of being thrust into the limelight
after being you know sort of hidden in
this camper and then all of a sudden
your story is known and and everybody
wants to talk to you um yeah they was
scary because I was very keen on
remaining anonymous in the beginning of
because you know first of all for peta
like safety reasons up you know you're a
woman and you feel very vulnerable you
know think how much like extra
vulnerable many raised stories about
like homeless people being set on fire
and stuff so i really didn't want people
to you know be able to connect my name
is limitation to live oh yeah there was
there was that it's just you know it's
very overwhelming I'm getting slightly
better at edits and it's still you know
very and it comes in when it's like
there will be an article done and all of
a sudden there'll be a lot of attention
and people when I talk to me in the
email fills a few of the Indian box
filled up with emails she does this
answer out and I'm like Oregon
overwhelmed and you know there are
moments where you're like al-qaeda my
bring in a short circuits and then you
know it'll kind of it'll die down a
little and you may try to get back to
everybody and you know just keep
plugging on so it's this exciting i call
it kind of like quasi z-list internet
fame yeah I'm not luckily I don't you
know I don't get recognized walking down
the street which is good um yeah I think
that would be kind of scary but you know
if it's good it is a good feeling to
kind of know that your opinions is being
taken seriously because I I never felt
like I had a voice turn signals before
this I think a lot of people who are you
know race in abusive situations feel
that way and so you know it's kind of an
odd feeling that people are listening to
you or you know think that what you have
to say has any value or but here people
are like oh you're an expert on
homelessness I'm like wait what no I'm
not still getting used to that whole you
know thing of you know what I have to
say in the experience I've had better
show if it's exciting of parity on the
media side of that I mean how did you
end up on the front page of yahoo do you
have any involvement with making that
happen you know same thing with
with the Today Show I mean is that is
that you doing that how does that happen
no I'm gonna be well does the Today Show
happened when the I met my fiancé at the
time he was big in social media and so
he written a story about it and I think
he got picked up on dig and so it became
like a really big story and it made the
front page dig into that kind of
construct me outlets know whether they
have a whole thing kind of started but
you know the Today Show stuff like they
call on their own and then you know now
what's the program i'm sure that you
know that publisher you know they keep
some outreach answer there too but I
don't you know I don't have a ton of
knowledge about about social media how
it all works um and then the young thing
was a reporter that has been an
energy-rich mean last year he was kind
of doing a follow-up so that was in US
News and World Report then I think they
just kind of picked up on it and my
first I haven't read it I try not to
read the comment sections i certainly
get quite passionate over there um you
know and there's some debate so I try to
stay away from comments sections because
you know some people make a lot of
knee-jerk assumptions and you know they
can say painful things so I learned that
it's kind of good to stay away from that
side just try to focus on the cob their
body your life yes sounds like
definitely a safer place to be is sort
of a void where where those comments can
go but but you know is there anything
you can share um you know in regards to
and dealing with the media pitching your
story to the media is anything you can
share along those lines that you've
learned oh yeah I'm kind of thinking of
picking it up as I go um you know
obviously I think you have headlines are
everything this is what I'm learning and
you know something was with a catchy you
know attention grabber wolf will get
people's attention you know hope this is
a hot-button more right now so I'm sure
that kind of helped in that in the media
beginning department you know anything
recessions a trend and yeah you try to I
mean I learned like I had to put
together a marketing proposal for the
book when
the move was first thing they're shocked
around and you know you pick up stuff
like you know how to phrase things USA
well who you want to be able to put out
there and no I'm working in marketing
which I've never done forces I'm
learning what it's like you know you
would find out who's your audience and
who's going to read this and why and
that's what I guess you know the media
or anyone else you know wants to know
when when you know something being
shopped around seven where will this
appeal to people who's going to read it
my demographic and what are similar
stories than her you know done Weller or
grab the attention that you know that
this could be in there too and going
back to when you began blogging how are
you initially approached about the book
oh I'll i was approached once or twice
i'm in the very beginning by a couple
literary agents and i have turned it
down because i was like oh god no are
you crazy um I didn't you know I didn't
want my name and face out there and I
didn't think I write books and so when I
finally started meeting with people
after my name is face were already out
there and it was when today show on CNN
happens and all of a sudden mendler
numerous literary agent swimming the
time to me so I was in New York
crustacea I met with a couple of them
and you know there was one I really
connected with and so I was lucky as if
you know what writers have to go out
there and you know submit and it to
agent after agent accept a lot of
rejection and I was really lucky won't
has been coming up to me so I feel bad
about that and I'm like I'm sorry
writers up there I I totally you know I
feel bad time like i said hey my views
of the accessibility of and here then
once you get a chance a kind of held my
hand and walking through the process
because i knew and still know very
little about Larry excited phone and I
asked you know my publishers of my
agents don't question everyday bit you
know I'm going to even people probably
actually know the answer to so I'm just
kind of now I'm getting it as I go but
yeah I'm telling you agent soy to go
they'll then walk you through it you
know so I mean you have your blog you
know and forgive me I don't know how
much material you had on your blog and
it isn't exciting yet you have someone
comes
and say look we want we want you to
write a book we want you know want to
publish it but at the same time you're
gonna have to fill in that gap I mean
this you know that this is a this is a
thick book here it's not it's not a
small books yeah we're gonna have to
write the rest these pages what must
most of what's in the book isn't on the
blog I didn't want to just like put it
in a bunch of blog posts in Yunnan
rehashes um you know which I had you
know good you guys here and a half hour
worth of material on the blog that you
know might have added up to almost that
much but I didn't want to like you know
I felt like that would be cheating like
oh you know here's something you can get
for free online but i'm just going to
like you know find it together and hold
a book so you know it was really
important to me to go more in depth and
share my backstory and hear things that
weren't already off on the blog so that
was you know kind of a daunting prospect
but you know again i'm really glad i did
it and it was cathartic I mean what did
it come easy or was it frustrating
putting it putting in a year and a half
worth of work on the hook there was um
you know there were moments where it was
it was frustrating or it seemed like it
was a big challenge like I think once I
actually jumped in and got started yes
and it kind of seemed slow more
naturally than I thought it would
because I was like okay I'm just writing
what I know I'm writing my life and
that's already happened to me so but it
was the whole getting started like just
sitting down and going you know where do
I start and how and there were times
where I would like to set it aside and
like I can't I can't do it for you a
month or two and I just can't read
anything with all the cement sit down
and you know that I would spend like 10
days you know working all night you know
reading and going ok so it just kind of
came in spurts um but yet it seemed a
lot more daunting than a weapon yeah I
think part of the challenges make me
something of a nice big mental block
about it and you know i'd like to home
before i ever wrote a second book fit
yeah now that i've done once I know I to
do it so it would be much less
horrifying so now you're working this
full-time job you're probably commuting
you have life to do but how are you
building your audience how much time are
you spending on it with Facebook and
Twitter and how do you how do you
prioritize your time with these emails
i'm sure some days it's just
overwhelming it
I was like the yahoo article I've still
got a few hundred emails and tweets
ready to get back to and from doing them
I wish I you know I feel like I should
be spending more time on on Twitter and
Facebook and stuff because that you know
social media so with each other the way
to reach people and so I you know but
I've also got the nine-to-five job going
so it's been you know kind of tricky you
know working that the schedule run
getting every everything covered and I'm
also doing the book tour stuff i have
another thing I'm trying to like
coordinate late for your for schedules
but yeah I'm man its Facebook social
media Twitter and those are those are
just University big left there's dozens
of social media sites it really is the
wave of the future you know you hear
that few people saying oh the news is
dead or useful first and I don't think
I'm quite true i think they're going to
involve or they are evolving as time
goes but you know social media now is
like right on the same you know and get
something before the move right there so
you know i think that the way we view
the world and use it is changing with
that yeah i'm also getting out of social
media wagon and switching gears slightly
we all know have you seen any small
independent films this year who is no
independent film oh gosh see ya like I
actually have because I love indie films
now I'm trying to remember which ones oh
ok let's see just do they have to come
out this year can they have come out of
any time any time yeah ok sometimes I
watch old ones that I never heard of I
really love it a Japanese one called
swing girls about this little you know
this group of like Japanese like true
and misfits who end up putting together
like a brass band and it's fully
adorable and let's see what else what
else I same I love me you can't do
anything but your yeah we deal with a
lot of a good number of independent
filmmakers yeah you know just you know
so they're here and there we like to
just throw it out to our guests and just
kind of get a sense of what films or on
their rate
r and baby should be on our radar yeah I
really want to see the the one that's
come out called beginners with you and
Ewan McGregor and christopher plummer
that's supposed to be really good so
looking forward to that one but yeah I
really love indie films oh and I watch a
lot of like stuff like overseas BBC
miniseries because you know I'm like
some from from like 1982 I'm like the
burn Chester chronicles I've never heard
of that but it sounds like you'll be
interested in so I'm into that and all
their stuff I used to work at
Blockbuster Video and and so like nights
and weekends so that was my thing in
room becoming one of you know about the
newest release and I was like oh but
what about this movie from it from 10
years ago you know you love it oh yeah
kk i'll just telling me this morning how
often she would go to blockbuster and
always be looking for the sort of the
obscure independent film we were
literally just talking about that
similar that's really funny yeah and
they try to scare you towards the stuff
on the outside wall then you really /
mean you're like no no I'm try to find
you know something from you know from
Italy in 1997 so yeah and I know it may
be premature are there any ideas to turn
this into a film amazed not premature
excellent I guess they've been working
on it since before the book was even
written Mannix there were people asking
about the film stuff so that's kind of
exciting him so it's kind of an ongoing
thing you know I get the feeling to take
years and years and may not ever pan out
and you know might get shelf so I'm
trying to get my hopes up but there are
screenwriters working on an adaptation
right now of it and got people they're
interested in searching so if it's
really exciting and I'm sort of removed
from the process and I just met the
screenwriters was in New York with two
weeks ago for a first pass that was
really cool but yeah it's a very surreal
thing like what you one talks about
putting your story to the film and again
I don't know if it'll ever actually
happen but it is you know kind of a
really weird odd feeling and where can
people
the book um it's available at borders
barnes & noble indigo chapters your
local indie bookstore amazoncom walmart
and target i think have it now so yeah
it's pretty out there i'm really excited
a kind of weird walking to a bookstore I
thought then be like oh God but yeah so
pretty much wherever good books are sold
um you know Briana that we want to just
thank you for taking time out of your
day yeah are you i know i just i saw a
question Briana's we wrap up i'm just
wondering you know you're around 24 25
right now I don't read by okay so if you
meet other 26 year olds and maybe their
life consists of you know worrying about
the latest text from their friends or
different things and you know that
you've dealt with things that most
people and their lifetime will never
experience how are you able to turn that
into saying well you know maybe this was
just I was put on this earth for lessons
of survival or or or trying to take the
high road with it instead of instead of
maybe harboring some type of feelings of
resentment how are you able to transcend
that yeah well I mean you can't really
represent you know that I'm I mean if
anything I'm happy that most people
haven't had to go to cruise hear stuff
like that you know who would want to you
know I think you know and there's a way
to reach people without being preachy I
tried to be preaching to people don't
like being preached cheap and they knew
like you know hearing the stories and so
I'm just trying to be really
conversational about it you know I mean
I don't like what I'm at work I don't
talk a lot about my book or my work and
you know some people found out about it
and they asked about it and then you
know that's the chance to kind of share
with people and maybe change perceptions
but know if you're just you know down
there University conversational and you
know people like that and they like the
approachable road and then you have two
things happen for you well I mean Briana
this is a very powerful book you know
and it's inspiring when you have a
chance to connect with someone
who's been able to endure and move on
and find that the positive and bright
side of life so we want to thank you for
joining us blogger author Brianna carp
the girls guide to homelessness you can
find out more about Briana at a girls
guide to homelessness calm you can find
a home with a girls guide to
homelessness forgive me you can find
there at twitter by just using the first
letter TG g th so that that's your
twitter handle ah and facebook your you
know the girls guide to homelessness as
well on facebook thank you so much for
having me it's been such a pleasure
don't think I really care you guys
taking the time to do the interview oh
and we just want to wish you the very
best and you know you just have such an
amazing story and and I just feel that
so many people can benefit from hearing
about it and even people that have never
lived in an abusive situation or been
homeless but just sort of that lesson of
being able to stand up and overcome and
I just really think it's important it
thank you for sharing it thank you so
much hurt very kind of you thank you
thank you thank you ya better great dad
ok you too